it's been a painful three years for
schools they shut down they went remote
they reopened and now they have to stay
open but for many students the
challenges really began even before the
school bell rang because they have to
get to school it starts right here with
the school bus we're talking about the
labor shortage in the school bus
industry and it's having major effects
on students and families
[Music]
so let's talk about the folks who do
apply for the school bus driver position
what's the typical profile at least
before the pandemic and how has that
changed sure so before the pandemic
there were two buckets of people that
would apply and now at post pandemic one
of those buckets has gone extinct the
first one these are union paying jobs
that offer health benefits and pension
benefits and 401k depending on the
company so you have potential applicants
that come in that see hey you know i
need family health benefits this seems
like a job where i can you know
grow within my community and i can
receive these benefits so they apply for
that the second one we were the tyrees
you know the retirees have really fallen
off we've asked them to come back in hey
we have these other positions that are
now coming up we'll let you work am pm
whatever you can create your own
schedule that will work with you of
course and we don't see them it's the
health susceptibility it's it's it's
very very it's all covered related
unlike other comparable jobs driving a
school bus requires jumping through a
number of hoops culminating with getting
a commercial driver's license which can
often take weeks so it's a regulatory
marathon you know not only do you have
the the drug testing you have a physical
you have a
uh you have a fingerprinting you have to
pass five different written tests and
then you have the road test and people
who put in the time to get the necessary
training and license can often find
similar paying work that's not tied to
the daily school schedule or school
being in session i would say that the
largest threat to the industry has
become amazon the biggest thing that
happened during the pandemic when the
school buses were shut down is delivery
services boomed many of our potential
applicants went there instead so the
school bus industry could be recession
proof but it's not pandemic proof
whereas delivery services have proven
they're not only pandemic proof they're
pandemic booming the shortage is so
severe that in some states the national
guard was activated to fill the gaps
they're not sustainable solutions the
national guard's there to protect us
they're not there to be cdl school bus
drivers so it's a little bit different
for them this is a whole new area for
them where you don't have professional
experienced drivers on the road like
every other industry school bus
operators are increasing pay to attract
job seekers but it's complicated because
taxpayers often end up getting the final
say so here's the issue obviously you
want to give good raises you want to
give competitive benefits you want to
have a competitive pay scale but the
problem is is you're a business and you
have to pass that on to the school
district and then that becomes a vicious
cycle of fighting of who's responsible
for what and rebidding so i'm nervous
about inflation i'm nervous about the
supply chain and the demand
and uh
i don't know what gets done to mitigate
that so corey has to be creative and
pull the levers that are available to
him sure so we're offering sign-on
bonuses that this industry has never
seen we're offering
paint
but give me an idea between 2 500 and 3
and we're offering paid training uh
we're offering the training class to get
on the road immediately on the vans and
then go go to type c if you can only
work the pm we'll take you fine we'll
take whatever we could get you only want
to do three hours at four o'clock at
night we'll put you on a charter or a
field trip then there are the
intangibles the emotional rewards of
driving a bus here's what some of
corey's drivers say they love about
their job the best part
people the kids you know having
conversation with them
we spend more time with the kids than
their parents do because their parents
go to work so we see them more so they
become like a part of that family
i mean this seems to be a selling point
if you're trying to get
new recruits as school bus drivers yeah
and i think uh you know the bottom line
too i think people want meaningful and
purposeful work you know i mean you got
one shot at this so and and i feel like
you know when people come in and they
start they start talking to me you know
current employees you clearly see that
they're making a difference in the
community and and they enjoy that with
every part of the school system in need
of staff some drivers are now lending a
hand inside the school buildings too
we have plenty of drivers that drive the
kids to school park their buses in the
back parking lot and then they become
lunch ladies or lunch servers and things
like that or they become security guards
for the middle of the day and that ties
back into you know
extra money extra revenue an extra job
source but also being a part of that
community
as we try to figure out the new normal
we can all appreciate the value of being
part of something bigger than yourself
i admit i kind of like the idea of being
in the bus driver's seat someday
but until i go through all the training
corey would only let me pretend for now
producer back there you gotta sit down
we're gonna take off soon
[Music]